تختلف تصريحات وزير الدفاع الروسي
عن ما يقوله قائد قوات
تتباين مع ما تروجه السلطات الاوكرانيه
بما يخص انسحاب الجيش الروسي من محاور في
مدينه باخموت يقول بان ذخيره التي تصنعها
الدفاع الروسيه تكفي لامداد الجيش على
جميع الجبهات وسط تحصينات دفاعيه مكثفه في
ذات الوقت الذي اكد فيه بريجوجن انه خسر
اعدادا كبيره من مقاتله بسبب نقص الذخيره
لدى قواته اما جيش الاوكراني فيقول ان
عملياته العسكريه المضاده في طور الانطلاق
وان قوات فاجنر بدات بالانسحاب من مدينه
باخمت على عكس ما يقوله برجي الذي يؤكد
سيطره قواته على معظم اجزاء المدينه
وتبقي اقل من ثلاثه كيلو مترات لاكمال
السيطره على بخمر وبين هذا وذاك يسود
الحذر والترقب المشهد في مناطق
الانفصاليين الموالين لروسيا بانتظار بدء
المعارك الطاحنه التي وعدت باشعالها
اوكرانيا بينما يستمر القصف المتبادل بين
طرفي النزاع وعلى جميع المحاور في مقاطعه
مخلفا مزيدا من القتلى والجرحى ومن
المدنيين والجنود على حد سواء
لقناتي العربيه والحدث رائد الاغبر دانيسك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات